Welcome, everybody.
We have Dhruv here with us today and
he's a product engineer at Udacity.
So Dhruv, tell us the story about how
you learned your first framework.
>> The first framework I used was
in college, it was Ruby on Rails.
And people will usually teach you
frameworks as a starting point into
building your first application because
it takes away a lot of the decisions and
complexities for you.
So you can just jump into a framework,
learn it,
and ideally get building your first
application in a couple days.
So that was the first
general framework I used.
The first front-end specific
framework I used was Angular.
I used it in a summer
internship in my senior year.
And again, at the time I thought it
was like nothing I'd ever seen, but
it helped me get moving quickly
into routing, building views,
and generally getting the fundamental
design patterns of the web quickly.
>> So now that you're
working with one framework,
how difficult was it to
switch to a new framework?
>> The truth is a lot of
these frameworks come from
radically different paradigms.
So Angular and React have very
different philosophies about things.
But a lot of them do
share commonalities.
So for instance,
if you go between Angular and
Ember, both are generally MVC
frameworks, and if you know one,
you get the guiding principles or
the idea behind the others.
A framework like React comes at
it from a very different way.
But knowing another framework helps you
evaluate another framework you're using.
So knowing Angular helped me understand
a lot more about why React is useful,
what were the guiding philosophies
that made it unique and
appealing to developers, and
understanding the trade-offs
that came with it compared to
a system like Angular or Ember.
>> Okay, so
if you are learning frameworks,
you shouldn't just find your first
one and stick with that for life.
You should experience the other ones,
build something with them, see what
are the needs of your application, and
then pick the best framework for that.
>> Definitely,
I think that's a very good answer.
There are some frameworks
that are fairly impractical,
but I learned them anyways because they,
again,
teach you philosophies and ideas of
approaching programming that are unique.
So in particular I checked out Elm lang,
which is a very functional approach
to doing front-end programming.
I've looked at ClojureScript a lot,
again, another very functional
perspective to doing programming.
And these have all affected how I
view the frameworks I use today.
And in addition to just
looking at what works for
you at this given point in time,
it's also worth looking at what the
general community is working towards.
Because if you work with the community,
you're going to get a lot of tools,
a lot of resources
that you wouldn't get otherwise if
you choose a very niche framework.
So there's a lot of considerations
to make, but understanding that
not all frameworks are perfect and that
every framework might not be perfect for
the job you're choosing is
a very good place to start.
>> So what is some advice that you would
give to students that are looking to
dive into the world of frameworks?
>> To start by not looking at the
fine-grain details of how to implement
X, Y, or Z in a framework, although
you'll have to do that in your app.
But at some point,
to take a step back and try and
figure out what's the philosophy
of this framework.
A framework is essentially some
really smart people somewhere have
designed this intricate system to
help you accomplish something.
There's a lot to learn in just
looking at how it was designed, and
you can reuse a lot of those
concepts in future things you build.
So the first thing is just looking at
the framework, understanding it, and
understanding how it was created or
what the decisions were.
Frameworks are always going to be good
at some things and bad at some things.
Understanding those trade-offs and
learning to appreciate those.